Oh
[ __ ] you think you're dealing with
[ __ ] bad flavor my main man Steve
Simone stuck in bumper the [ __ ]
bumper traffic most people would take
this car and go over the [ __ ] turn
relevation like guns and roses says
[ __ ] you gotta have patience
[ __ ] people
but never fear uncle Joey's here even
when this traffic their stars at that
God always have the Stars and paste this
traffic understand you gotta be so bad
preparation is to keep the lifebook left
Adam right here my fingertips I'm eating
them like [ __ ] hot poured on a movie
theater you understand Oh drop that one
will crash this [ __ ] car
the Dark Side of the Moon do that deaton
stars like a [ __ ] let's do this
[ __ ] [ __ ] that's it I'm out of
stars at like five or six of them and a
quick getaway [ __ ] package I always
have
a little bit of water look in the guy
next to me Jonny Wu little [ __ ] wah
wah that's it you people thinking out
the world by the ball look at this is on
for the [ __ ] bumper traffic thanks
apps coming over with look at these
[ __ ] morons it is look at
that's blocking traffic ladies and
gentlemen you understand me but we're
here for you by still [ __ ] up what are
you gonna do Steve Simone looking
handsome as ever let me get something
else out of their nostril drop those
[ __ ] they close this up
description
and that's it by the [ __ ] I just want to
touch base to him and let you know God
loves you God loves you yo uncle Joey
loves you
have a great weekend behave yourselves
we'll be back Sunday night with the
church
next week you know we got [ __ ]
crackalackin colors diesel boat this
weekend cherokee casino that's right
we're hanging with the Indians [ __ ]
those two guys in sonic they can suck my
dick will the new two dudes from Sonic
and [ __ ] [ __ ] all that nonsense [ __ ]
calling people and let his little blonde
next to me she's bangin this little
blonde next to me is on fire check it
out she's got the windows open that
means that put on I'm trying to show you
this little cute